candace owens is the host of candace she
joins us tonight candace thanks so much
for coming on maybe i'm being too soft
but anybody who can talk you know
america's
woke corporate structure into sending
close to 100 million dollars on the
basis of that lame rap
kind of gets my respect in a way
she has my respect because she's
unapologetic in her approach she's
telling you what she is she's a marxist
so marxists
steal money from other people and they
enrich themselves until the people that
they stole from are poor and so she
has stolen money from other people on
the pretext of a lie that is black lives
matter
and she's enriched herself and she's
brought four homes i mean you have to
kind of appreciate the honesty she's not
hiding by any means you know and so yeah
i tend to agree with you here she's a
communist through and through and she's
been unbelievably unapologetic in her
approach
al sharpton must be looking at this and
saying like i've done this for 40 years
where did i go wrong i don't have a
house in topanga canyon
right exactly right it's completely
ridiculous and you know you're right the
corporations are
are standing behind her which is
incredibly interesting and you pointed
to something really important
you know these corporations that are
pouring millions and millions of dollars
into black lives matter and you
correctly said
we raised more than 90 million dollars
how much more we will never know but 90
million dollars of which 21 million
dollars apparently went to
according to black lives matter
themselves it went to um
building the black movement like i don't
even know what that means
25 million dollars going to building a
black movement
apparently the black movement was
patrice moving herself a black woman
moving herself
uh into other areas of the communities
of people that she claims
are oppressing black americans she's
fearful of white people why people are
so bad
well why doesn't she want to live
amongst black people why is she choosing
to move herself into an all-white
neighborhood these are important
questions
yeah i think they are it's not it's
topanga canyon not riverside county
i really quickly the looting that we're
seeing in minneapolis
was just reflexive this police shooting
does sound like it raises questions of
the competence of the police officer and
what's going on with the minneapolis
police department maybe they've lowered
the standards maybe there aren't
you know enough cops who knows we should
find out i think but
looting in immediate response to that
why would we put up with that
we shouldn't put up with that but the
reason why we do is because
the democrats see some advantage in this
right so right now you have a bunch of
criminals that love black lives matter
as an organization they love when a
black person dies
and we don't know what the reasons are
we don't know what happened but it
signals to them that they are now
allowed to run into the streets
and grab whatever they want whether it's
from target whether it's from walmart
and what's remarkable also is that these
corporations are standing behind black
lives matter right they're they're
pouring money into these corporations
and i remember most notably during the
george floyd riots uh target even came
out and said we don't even care that we
were right and looted because we just
stand with black lives matter
that's not a normal thing for a
corporation to do when it's losing money
so that means that a corporation must be
getting something else
right what is it what are they investing
in when they
invest in the lie that is black lives
matter what is the return
i think josh hawley alluded to it in the
previous segment and i think you're on
something when you say that the
corporations seek to control this
country they're willing to give up money
they're willing to let their swords you
ride in looted because they see
something bigger
that they're gaining from these riots
and these looting these lootings and
these lies
and that is control over this country
it's power and it's sinister and it's
sick
and if some pakistani liquor store owner
is destroyed in the process like you
think jeff bezos cares
no uh kenneth owens so nicely put as
always it's great to see you
thank you